We are getting ready to plan some travel for the holidays and so we've started to look on Airbnb We love to stay at an Airbnb because when you travel with children and your family It is nice to have a kitchen. It's nice to have you all in one area Jenna, I got a hot tip for you. What is it? Do you know that you could make money off of your home while you're away on vacation? Tell me more. I will. While you're away, your home could be an Airbnb.
我们正准备策划一次假日旅行，所以我们开始在Airbnb上寻找房源。我们非常喜欢住在Airbnb，因为当你和孩子以及家人一起旅行时，能有一个厨房感觉真好。能让大家都在同一个起居区域待着也很棒。珍娜，我有一个特别的建议要告诉你。是什么呀？你知道当你外出度假时，你的家也能为你赚钱吗？详细说说。好呀。你不在家的时候，你的家可以当成Airbnb出租。
Oh, really? Yeah, think about someone who's frequently traveling. You know? Yeah. While they're away, their home's making them money. That's pretty sweet. I know. That's very Shroot Farms of them. Although Dwight doesn't leave. That's pretty sweet. I know. That's very shrewt farms of them. Although Dwight doesn't
哦，真的吗？对啊，想想那些经常出差的人。你知道吧？对啊。他们不在家的时候，家里还能帮他们赚钱。这挺不错的。我知道。他们这操作真够舒鲁特农场的。虽然德怀特不离开。这挺不错的。我知道。他们这操作真够舒鲁特农场的。虽然德怀特不
leave. That's true and if he did leave you'd be stuck with Moe's. Yes. Well it sounds like Airbnb is a really practical way to earn some extra money. If you've stayed at an Airbnb wouldn't it be cool to give that experience to others? Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.com slash host. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door.
离开。确实，要是他真的走了，你可就只能跟莫斯（Moe's）凑合了。没错。听起来Airbnb确实是一种赚取外快的好方法。如果你住过Airbnb，把那种体验带给其他人不是很酷吗？你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。上airbnb.com/host了解一下能值多少钱。有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、纹理完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？一块由Instacart采购员精心挑选并送到你门前、在烧烤架上滋滋作响的纹理完美的肋眼牛排。
A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver.
一块你甚至不用离开戏水池就能下单的纹理完美的肋眼牛排。无论你的夏天需要采购什么杂货，Instacart都能满足你。下载Instacart应用程序，前三单即可享受0美元配送费。服务费、排除条款和适用条款均适用。Instacart，超值交付的杂货。
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hey there.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来了终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后花絮以及大量VFF（办公室好闺蜜）的故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妈 6.0。大家好。嘿，各位。
Today we're breaking down another webisode. Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hey there. Today we're breaking down another webisode, the mentor. And we're also gonna share mentor stories. From you guys who wrote in plus some of our own. Yes, but first before we get started on all of that, can I do a personal share? Yeah, what's going on?
今天我们要解析另一集网络短剧。辣妈 6.0。大家好。嘿，各位。今天我们要解析另一集网络短剧《导师》。我们还将分享导师的故事。来自你们写信投稿的内容，再加上我们自己的一些经历。没错，但在我们开始所有这些之前，我能先分享一个我个人的私事吗？可以啊，怎么了？
Do you want the long, medium, or short version of this story? Actually, just pick medium or short. I'll go medium, okay? So, I got up this morning and I thought, today is a drawstring pant day. Oh, I love those days. I mean, I've been putting in more effort when we come into the studio. I only have to work outside of the house.
你想听这个故事的长版、中版还是短版？其实，选个中版或短版就行。那我选个中版吧，好吗？所以，我今天早上起床后心想，今天是个穿抽绳长裤的日子。哦，我最喜欢那种日子了。我是说，我们来工作室的时候，我其实付出了更多努力。我一周只需要出一次门工作，
One day a week, okay? Only one day you need to look super cute, unless there's a school thing. True. Yeah. But today, even though it was not a work-from-home day, I was like, I just feel so good in my pajama pants. What can I wear? But then I took a shower.
一周就一天，好吧？只有一天你需要看起来超级可爱，除非有学校的活动。确实。对啊。但今天，尽管不是那种在家办公的日子，我还是心想，我穿睡裤感觉太舒服了。我能穿什么呢？但接着我去洗了个澡。
And after the shower, I thought, you know what? Make the effort, Jenna. It's one day a week. Yeah. Now I am still wearing a drawstring pant, but I put in an effort. And I thought I'm going to put on the makeup. Because by the way, I wasn't going to put on makeup either.
洗完澡后，我想，你知道吗？加把劲吧，珍娜。一周才出一次门。好吧。现在我虽然还穿着一条抽绳长裤，但我确实打扮了一下。我想我还是化个妆吧。顺便说一下，我本来也没打算化妆的。
But when you say drawstring pant, you're not in sweatpants. These look like sort of a khaki, kind of green trouser. Yeah, they are an elastic waist trouser. Oh, well, I'm here for it. Thank you. I mean, it's a happy middle ground. Okay. But this isn't even about my pants. I don't know. That's the medium part of the story,
但当你提到抽绳长裤时，你可不是穿的那种运动裤。这些看起来有点像卡其色、有点偏绿的长裤。对，它们是松紧腰的长裤。哦，那我太支持了。谢谢。我是说，这是一个皆大欢喜的折中方案。好啦。但这甚至都跟我的裤子无关。我不懂。这是故事的中等长度版本，
which was that my instinct, the point of this is my instinct was, make almost no effort today and that will make you happy. And I went against my instinct and I decided to put on makeup and all the whatever. And while I was putting on my makeup, I stabbed myself in the eye with my mascara wand. Oh, God. And it still hurts. It's so painful when that happens. I hope I don't need to go to the eye doctor after this recording. I mean, I think I'm OK. Can I guess which eye it is looking at you?
也就是说我的直觉——重点是，我的直觉是：今天几乎不要费力打扮，那会让你快乐。但我违背了自己的直觉，决定化个妆以及搞这搞那。就在我化妆的时候，我用睫毛膏刷把自己的眼睛给戳了一下。哦，天哪。现在还疼呢。发生这种事的时候可真够受罪的。我希望录完音后不用去看眼科医生。我是说，我觉得我没事。看着你，我能猜到是哪只眼吗？
Guess which one. Is it your right eye? Yes. Because it's a little puffy in the corner. Of course, yes, it hurts. Oh, honey. I am still recovering. And it was a good like 90 minutes ago.
猜猜是哪只。是你的右眼吗？对。因为眼角有点肿。当然啦，对啊，好疼呀。哦，亲爱的。我还在恢复中。而且那是足足90分钟前的事了。
I wouldn't have noticed right away, but since you said it, now I'm looking at it and, lady, you got yourself good. I really did. So I don't know what the moral of that story is, but I think if you are feeling like it's a low effort day, just listen to yourself. I wish I'd just listened to myself. Why the mascara today? Clearly I didn't want it.
我本来不会马上发现的，但既然你都这么说了，现在我看着它……天哪，老兄，你把自己戳得可真够狠的。我真的是。所以我不知道那个故事的寓意是什么，但我觉得如果你觉得今天是个不想费力的一天，就听从你自己的直觉吧。我真希望当时就听自己的。今天为什么非要用睫毛膏？很显然我根本不想用。
You were rejecting it. Your whole body was like, no. So that's it. That was my share. I hope it gets better. Thank you. We also had a guest in our studio today. We did.
你在排斥它。你的整个身体都在说：不要。所以就是这样。这就是我的分享。希望它快点好起来。谢谢。我们今天工作室里还有一位客人。对啊。
We have a guest in our studio. The cutie patootie, Ramin is here. Can Ramin say something into the microphone? Sure. Please hold. Ramin. Hey buddy. Sam's dog is Ramin for anyone who doesn't know, I guess. Ramin, you want to say hi to office ladies? Can you say hi? He's licking the mic. He's licking the mic. Yay. Aw. Oh my gosh. He's so cute. He's so cute. Okay.
我们工作室里来了一位客人。那个小可爱雷明（Ramin）来啦。雷明能对着麦克风说句话吗？当然可以。请稍等。雷明。嘿，老兄。不了解的人可能会问，萨姆的狗就叫雷明，我想。雷明，你想跟办公室辣妈的听众打个招呼吗？你能说个“嗨”吗？他在舔麦克风。他在舔麦克风。耶。啊。噢天哪。他太可爱了。他太可爱了。好啦。
Well, let's get into it because I think this is gonna be a really fun episode despite my achy eye. I wanted to kick things off with an article actually. This is from Screen Rant and it's about the webisode, The Mentor, which Angela, you are the star of. Oh, I don't know about that.
好了，我们开始正题吧，因为我觉得这将是非常有趣的一集，尽管我的眼睛还在隐隐作痛。其实我本来想用一篇文章来开个头。这篇文章来自Screen Rant，讲的是网络短剧《导师》，安吉拉，你可是里面的主角哦。噢，我可不知道是不是这样。
What? I mean, me and Ellie, it's not a solo. Like we're a dynamic duo and it was so fun. It's a nice two-hander. Yeah. But this is like, this is an Angela Martin A story. It is and that, you know, didn't happen very often. So it was really fun.
什么？我是说，我和埃丽（Ellie），这不是独角戏。我们就像是一个充满活力的二人组，而且太有趣了。这是一部很棒的双人戏。对啊。但这就好像是一部安吉拉·马丁专属的主线故事。确实是的，而且你知道的，这并不常发生。所以真的很有趣。
Well, when I read this article, it made me smile. So I want to read it. Here's what it said. The Mentor is such an incredible work. It's a shame it never aired on TV. In this webisode that released in 2010, we find Erin, board of her job. She wished to be as collected as the accounting department and asked the group if they'd be willing to help her. Shockingly, Angela tells Erin she'd be her mentor because she sees great promise in Erin. Not only did Angela teach Erin how to do her job, but she taught her how to dress, sit,
嗯，当我读到这篇文章时，它让我笑了。所以我想读一读。它是这么写的：《导师》是一部如此不可思议的作品。真遗憾它从未在电视上播出过。在这部2010年发布的网络短剧中，我们发现埃琳对她的工作感到厌烦。她希望自己能像会计部门的人那样沉着冷静，并询问大家是否愿意帮她。令人震惊的是，安吉拉告诉埃琳她愿意当她的导师，因为她在埃琳身上看到了巨大的潜力。安吉拉不仅教埃琳如何工作，还教她如何穿衣、落座
and behave. And she delighted in it. Angela loved having a trainee. I know! She was like so animated. But I do think this speaks to the point that some of these webisode plot lines, they would have made great full office episodes as well. That's why they're so good.
以及举止。而且她对此乐此不疲。安吉拉很喜欢有个实习生。我知道！她当时简直生气勃勃。但我确实认为这说明了一个问题，那就是其中一些网络短剧的剧情线，本来也可以拍成非常棒的《办公室》完整剧集的。这就是它们为什么这么棒。
Yeah. And satisfying, I think. I think so, too. Well, I'll share about it as we go. And, you know, one thing I did remember is that we did like a little mini press day and Ellie and I did interviews and I found one on TV Fanatic all about the webisode. I'll share it in our stories, but it did feel kind of special, you know?
对啊。而且我觉得很满足。我也这么觉得。好吧，待会儿我们边聊边分享吧。而且，你知道，我记得的一件事是，我们当时做了一点小型的媒体日活动，埃丽和我接受了采访，我在TV Fanatic上找到了一篇全关于这部网络短剧的采访。我会把它分享到我们的快拍里，但感觉确实有点特别，你知道吗？
Well, we also reached out to Kelly Cantley about directing The Mentor because it was her directorial debut. Mm-hmm. I also spoke with Nate Fetterman who wrote it along with Jonathan Hughes. I asked him, how did this one come about? And Nate said that Kelly Cantley, our first AD,
对了，我们还联系了凯莉·坎特利（Kelly Cantley）来执导《导师》，因为这是她的导演处女作。嗯哼。我还跟撰写该剧的内特·费特曼（Nate Fetterman）以及乔纳森·休斯（Jonathan Hughes）聊过。我问他，这一集是怎么构思出来的？内特说，凯莉·坎特利，我们的第一副导演（1st AD），
was assigned to direct, but since she didn't have a writing background, like some of the other directors we worked with on other webisodes did, he said he believes Aaron Shor, who was on our writing team, was asked to supervise the writing. And so Jonathan and Nathan pitched ideas.
被委任担任导演，但由于她没有像我们合作过其他网络短剧的一些导演那样具有编剧背景，他说他相信我们的编剧团队成员亚伦·肖尔（Aaron Shor）被邀请来监督剧本创作。于是乔纳森和内特就提出了各种创意。
And of all those ideas, the one he picked was the mentor. And then Nate and Jonathan wrote it from there. So that's how this one came about. And then Kelly got picked to direct. Well, this is something I loved about our show, that people would get an opportunity to spread their wings and really shine. I went into my digital clutter lady to see what I could find from this time. Not specifically to this webisode,
而在所有这些创意中，他选中的就是《导师》。然后内特和乔纳森就在此基础上完成了剧本。这就是这一集诞生的过程。接着凯莉就被选为导演。嗯，这也是我非常喜欢我们剧组的一点，大家都有机会展翅高飞，真正大放异彩。我翻看了一下我的数字杂物堆，想看看能不能找出那个时期的一些东西。不是针对这部网络短剧的，
but in 2009, I found an email from our second, second assistant director, Stephanie Kinch, you remember Stephanie? Of course. And Rusty Mahmood, who was our other assistant director, and they wrote an email saying, hey guys, we're part of the DGA, the Directors Guild of America, mentor program,
但在2009年，我找到了一封来自我们的第二第二助理导演斯蒂芬妮·金奇（Stephanie Kinch）的邮件——你还记得斯蒂芬妮吧？当然啦。还有拉斯蒂·马哈茂德（Rusty Mahmood），他是我们的另一位助理导演，他们写了一封邮件说：“嘿，伙计们，我们加入了DGA，也就是美国导演工会（Directors Guild of America）的导师计划，
and we're gonna be having some trainees on set that we're gonna be mentoring. I remember them, I remember our DGA trainees. Yeah, if you wanna get into the Directors Guild of America Union for like assistant directing to be part of the AD staff, you have to go through this mentorship program and you get assigned to different sets
我们片场将会迎来一些实习生，我们将担任他们的导师。”我记得他们，我记得我们的DGA实习生。对啊，如果你想加入美国导演工会，从事助理导演的工作，成为助理导演团队的一员，你就必须通过这个导师计划，然后你会被分配到不同的片组，
for like a certain number of hours, if I remember correctly. Yeah, they would usually be at base camp, which is a pretty crazy way to enter the business, I think. Right, you're wrangling all of the actors. Yeah, you have to get them to hair and makeup, and you have to get them back from lunch, and you have to get them out of their trailers
实习一定的小时数，如果我没记错的话。对，他们通常会在大本营（Base Camp），我觉得以这种方式进入这个行业真的是相当疯狂。没错，你要负责统筹所有的演员。对，你得让他们去弄发型和化妆，你得让他们在午餐后归队，你得让他们从房车里出来，
and changed into their clothes. Yeah, it's a big job. But I just thought that was great that even on our own set, we were mentoring people. And you know, I do want to talk about working with Kelly as a director because we knew Kelly is our assistant director and we asked her how she prepared to direct for the very first time.
换上戏服。对，这是一项重大的工作。但我觉得很棒的一点是，即使在我们自己的剧组里，我们也在指导别人。而且你知道的，我确实想聊聊和作为导演的凯莉合作的感受，因为我们知道凯莉是我们的助理导演，我们问过她第一次当导演是怎么做准备的。
This was her first time directing. And her response made me chuckle. She said, I remember asking a few directors I liked working with if they had any advice for me. Charles McDougall told me to wear uncomfortable shoes. What? So I would stay alert and aware and to stay on set so anyone could find me if they had a question.
这是她第一次当导演。她的回答让我咯咯笑了。她说：“我记得我向几位我喜欢与之合作的导演询问，看他们能不能给我一些建议。查尔斯·麦克杜格尔（Charles McDougall）告诉我，要穿不舒服的鞋子。”什么？“这样我就会保持警觉和清醒，并且要留在片场，这样任何人有疑问都能找到我。”
Oh my gosh. Uncomfortable shoes. You're on your feet all day. All day. Well, what was it like working with Kelly as a first time director, Ange? Do you remember her feet being uncomfortable? I don't remember her feet. But I do remember that she showed up with a blazer and sort of like a really cute little
哦，天哪。穿不舒服的鞋子。你一整天都要站着。一整天。安吉，作为一个初次当导演的人，跟凯莉合作是什么感觉？你还记得她的脚穿得不舒服吗？我不记得她的脚了。但我确实记得她出现时穿了一件西装外套，还戴着那种非常可爱的、小小的
scarf. Which is very different from how she dressed as our first AD, which was usually in like a hoodie and like cargo pants. Yes, yes. I feel like as our first AD, she had tons of like scripts in her pockets and a walkie talkie and all this. And so she really showed up sort of like in this new look. Yeah.
围巾。这跟她当我们的第一副导演时的穿着大不相同，她以前通常穿着连帽衫和工装裤。对，对。我觉得当我们的第一副导演时，她的口袋里塞满了剧本、对讲机还有各种东西。所以她这次出现时真的是换了一种全新造型。对啊。
And she looked fantastic. And of course she was super prepared and she knew exactly what she wanted for every shot. There was no like kind of waffling, like, oh, do I put the camera here? No, she had a vision and that made it a really fun easy day. And you know, of course she knows the show so well and the characters so well. So it just was a great experience and I really enjoyed revisiting this episode.
而且她看起来棒极了。当然，她准备得超级充分，对每一个镜头都非常清楚自己想要什么。没有什么那种犹豫不决，比如“哦，我要把摄像机放在这里吗？”完全没有，她有自己的愿景，这让那天的工作变得既有趣又轻松。而且你知道的，她当然对这部剧和里面的角色了如指掌。所以这真的是一段非常棒的经历，我也很享受重新回顾这一集。
I can't wait to talk about it. And I reached out to Ellie Kemper and she shares some of her memories about it too. Well before we get to all that, to kick us off, let's share one of the letters we got. When we reached out, we said, we put a call to action into the world. We said, we wanna hear your mentor stories because we're gonna be talking about this webisode
我迫不及待想聊聊它了。我还联系了埃丽·坎珀（Ellie Kemper），她也分享了一些关于这集的回忆。好吧，在进入那些内容之前，我们先分享一封收到的来信来开个头。当我们发出邀请时，我们说，我们向世界发出了号召。我们说，我们想听听你们作为导师或被指导的故事，因为我们将要讨论这部网络短剧
and about mentorship in general. And this one came from Grace T. in Massachusetts, who said, hi, Office Ladies, I'm 15 and I'm a huge fan of The Office and your podcast. I've been through a lot of stuff in my life, but my mom, Emily, has always been my greatest supporter and mentor. I just love that this 15 year old is,
以及关于导师制度的普遍话题。这封信来自马萨诸塞州的格蕾丝·T.（Grace T.），她说：“嗨，办公室辣妈，我15岁，我是《办公室》和你们播客的超级粉丝。我的人生经历过很多事情，但我妈妈埃米莉（Emily）一直是我最坚定的支持者和导师。”我只是觉得这个15岁的女孩……
I know. Like, referring to her mom as her mentor. Grace went on to say, even when we don't get along, I know she's there for me. The biggest thing she's mentored me in has been running. And when it isn't cross country or track season, I run with her almost every day. Oh my gosh. She's really fostered my love for the sport. And since she ran in college herself, she's been helping me improve so much. I hope you share this on the podcast
我知道。就好像把她妈妈称作她的导师。格蕾丝接着说：“即使我们合不来，我也知道她一直在支持我。她指导我最多的事情就是跑步。当不是越野跑或田径赛季时，我几乎每天都跟她一起跑步。”哦，天哪。她真的培养了我对这项运动的热爱。而且因为她自己上大学时就跑过步，所以她一直在帮我取得很大的进步。我希望你们能在播客里分享这个，
so she knows how much she means to me. Aww. I love that. I love that they're bonding through running. Yeah. You know, Grace's letter reminded me that my sister is in a mentorship program that is centered around running and physical activity, and it's called Girls on the Run. And my sister has been one of the coaches for, my gosh, years now. That's awesome. I have never heard of that.
这样她就知道她对我有多重要了。噢。我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢她们通过跑步建立起深厚的感情。对啊。你知道，格蕾丝的信让我想起我姐姐也参加了一个以跑步和体育活动为核心的导师计划，叫做“奔跑吧女孩”（Girls on the Run）。我姐姐已经当了好几年——天哪——好几年的教练了。太棒了。我从来没听说过这个。
Yeah, she does one of the local St. Louis chapters, but it's a national organization. And I looked it up. It started in 1996 in Charlotte, North Carolina with a team of 13 gals. And then they just got together and started like running together. But also you're not just running,
对啊，她是圣路易斯当地分会的教练之一，但这是一个全国性的组织。我查了一下，它始于1996年北卡罗来纳州的夏洛特，当时是由13个女孩组成的一个团队。然后她们聚在一起，开始一起跑步。不仅是跑步，
you're sharing stories, you're pumping each other up. And also if you don't feel like running, you just walk it. But it's just this way to get girls together with female mentors. Yeah, community support. Yes, exactly. I love it. Yeah, community support. Yes, exactly. I love it. Yeah, and they host like 5K events across the United States.
你们还要分享故事，互相打气。而且如果你不想跑了，直接改成走路也行。这其实就是一种把女孩们和女性导师聚在一起的方式。对啊，社区支持。没错，完全是这样。我太喜欢了。对啊，社区支持。没错，完全是这样。我太喜欢了。对啊，他们还在全美各地举办5K跑活动。
And my sister does one every year. It's really sweet. She sends me the pictures and- I love this. I do not know this about your sister. And you know, my sister is not a runner or anything. She's not like, it sounds like Grace and her mom are like, they are pretty serious about it.
我姐姐每年都参加。真的太温馨了。她会把照片发给我——我太喜欢这个了。我还真不知道你姐姐有这经历。而且你知道，我姐姐并不是什么跑步爱好者。她不像——听起来格蕾丝和她妈妈对跑步相当认真，
But this is just about like activity, just like, you know, like you and I know, ladies, some of our best shares are when we're on a power walk together. Oh, I know. Right? A walk and talk. A walk and talk. That's where it all comes out.
但这个活动纯粹是关于运动，就像，你知道的，正如你我所知，女士们，我们最棒的分享时刻之一就是我们一起进行健步走的时候。哦，我懂。对吧？边走边聊。边走边聊。所有的真心话都是在那时候掏出来的。
That's right. Well, I love that. I think we should share about Girls on the Run and our stories. Definitely. And let's take a break I love that. I think we should share about Girls on the Run and our stories. Definitely. And let's take a break. When we come back, we're going to break down the mentor webisode.
没错了。好吧，我很喜欢这个。我觉得我们应该在快拍里分享一下“奔跑吧女孩”的故事。必须的。我们先休息一下。我很喜欢这个。我觉得我们应该在快拍里分享一下“奔跑吧女孩”的故事。必须的。我们先休息一下。回来后，我们要开始解析《导师》这集网络短剧了。
We're going to share more stories of mentorship. And for those of you who want to watch along with us, some of these webisodes are on YouTube, and then some are on Peacock. Again, we are not sponsored by Peacock, but I just want you to know where they are. Why are we not sponsored by Peacock at this point? But I want people to know where they can watch them.
我们将分享更多关于导师的故事。对于那些想跟我们一起观看的人，其中一些网络短剧可以在YouTube上找到，还有一些在Peacock上。再次说明，我们没有赞助商Peacock，但我只是想让你们知道它们在哪儿能看到。为什么我们现在还没有获得Peacock的赞助啊？但我确实想让大家知道他们可以在哪里观看。
I mean, I think, yes, good to share, but like, hello, the people at Peacock. I'm just saying. Jenna's like, hello. But I do want to tell you, even if you do go to the website, it's kind of hard to find them. Like you have to go under the office thing, you know, you click on the office and then you have to go under collections and then you scroll down and there's...
我是说，我觉得，是的，分享一下挺好，但是——天哪，Peacock的人呐。我只是随口说说。珍娜就像是在说：喂。但我确实想告诉你们，即使你上了他们的网站，也很难找到它们。比如你必须在“办公室”那个分类下面找，你知道的，你点击《办公室》，然后你必须进入“合集”分类，接着往下滚动，然后就有……
This is on the Peacock website. Yeah. And then there's the full library of webisodes. So if you're looking for them, I know they're there and a lot of them are also on YouTube. You know, the reason we're probably not sponsored by Peacock is because we're giving them too much free advertising. Oh. So I don't know. Maybe moving forward, I'm going to say you can find it on you know where. The internet. Until they start paying me the big dollars. They're definitely not going to pay us anything now. All right, let's take a break. And when we come back, we're going to break down the mentor
这是在Peacock网站上。对啊。然后那里有完整的网络短剧库。所以如果你在找它们，我知道它们就在那儿，而且很多也都在YouTube上。你知道，我们之所以可能没有获得Peacock的赞助，是因为我们给他们做了太多免费广告了。哦。所以，我不知道。也许接下来，我要说的是：你可以在你知道的地方找到它。互联网。除非他们开始付给我大把大把的真金白银。他们现在绝对什么都不会付给我们的。好了，我们休息一下。回来之后，我们将解析《导师》
webisode. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I just had a visit with my mom and I was kind of thinking about all the ways that she has really informed my life as an adult. And one of the things that I really admire about her is that she was always willing to ask for help when she needed it. For advocating for herself. Yeah. Well, you know, mental health awareness is growing now, but there's still progress to be made. Twenty-six percent of Americans who participated in a recent survey say they have avoided seeking
这集网络短剧。本节目由BetterHelp赞助播出。我刚才去看望了我妈妈，我脑子里一直在想她作为成年人是如何真正塑造了我生活的方方面面。我最佩服她的一点是，当她需要帮助时，她总是愿意主动寻求帮助。为了自己去积极争取。对啊。嗯，你知道，现在心理健康意识正在不断提高，但仍有进步的空间。在最近的一项调查中，有百分之二十六的参与者表示，他们曾因害怕遭到评判而避免寻求
mental health support due to fear of judgment. Well this Mental Health Awareness Month, let's encourage everyone to take care of their well-being and break the stigma. BetterHelp is fully online. It's making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. And you can easily switch therapists anytime at no cost. We're all better with help. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies.
心理健康支持。在这个心理健康意识月，让我们鼓励每个人照顾好自己的身心健康，打破偏见。BetterHelp完全在网上进行。它让心理治疗变得负担得起且方便快捷，为全球超过500万的用户提供服务。而且你可以随时免费轻松更换治疗师。有帮助，我们都会变得更好。今天就访问betterhelp.com/officeladies，在你的第一个月享受9折优惠。网址是betterhelp.com中的help拼写是H-E-L-P，斜杠office ladies。
I'm Emma Greede and I've spent the last 20 years building, running and investing in some incredible businesses. The more success I've had, the more people started coming to me with questions. How do you start a business? How do you raise money? How do I bounce back from failure?
我是埃玛·格里德（Emma Greede），在过去的20年里，我一直在创立、运营和投资一些非常了不起的企业。我取得的成功越多，向我提问的人也就越多。如何创业？如何筹集资金？如何从失败中恢复过来？
On my new podcast, Aspire with Emma Greed, I'll be answering these questions and more through weekly conversations with the smartest minds out there. Listen to and follow Aspire with Emma Greed and Odyssey podcast available now, wherever you get your podcasts. Samsung Vision AI televisions transform screens into intelligent solutions from the shows
在我的新播客《与埃玛·格里德一起渴望》（Aspire with Emma Greed）中，我将通过每周与最聪明的大脑进行对话，来回答这些以及更多问题。收听并关注由Wondery和Audacy播客推出的《与埃玛·格里德一起渴望》，现已上线，无论你在哪里收听播客都可以听到。三星Vision AI电视将屏幕转化为智能解决方案，从那些
that make us laugh to those that make us cry. Now your TV knows you more than ever, whether it's reviving old memories with AI upscaling or seamless hands-free control with universal gestures. This isn't just television, it's a whole new vision, because it isn't just about what's on, it's about who's watching. Learn more about Samsung Vision AI televisions at samsung.com. All right, we are back.
让我们开怀大笑的节目，到那些让我们潸然泪下的节目。现在，你的电视比以往任何时候都更懂你，无论是通过AI升频技术重温旧时光，还是通过通用手势实现无缝免提控制。这不仅仅是一台电视，它是一个全新的愿景，因为这不仅关乎屏幕上播放的内容，更关乎是谁在观看。在samsung.com上了解有关三星Vision AI电视的更多信息。好了，我们回来了。
Here we go, it's The Mentor directed by Kelly Cantley and written by Nate Fetterman and Jonathan Hughes. The cast for this webisode is Angela Kinsey, Ellie Kemper, Brian Baumgartner, Oscar Nunez, Creed Bratton, Kate Flannery, Mindy Kaling, and BJ Novak. Yes, BJ and Mindy are really funny in this, too. They really are. Well, this webisode series starts with part one titled The Pupil.
我们开始吧，这就是《导师》，由凯莉·坎特利执导，内特·费特曼和乔纳森·休斯编剧。这一集网络短剧的演员阵容有安吉拉·金西、埃丽·坎珀、布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳、奥斯卡·努涅斯、克里德·布拉顿、凯特·弗兰纳里、敏迪·卡灵和B·J·诺瓦克。对啊，B·J和敏迪在这里面也非常搞笑。他们真的很搞笑。好吧，这个网络短剧系列从第一部分开始，标题是《学生》。
And Erin is at front reception, and she's looking over the partition over into accounting. And I think she just thinks they're having the best time. Well, I mean, she's looking at them as if they are eating a giant buffet dinner. Like, very longingly. Yeah. She is, like, entranced. I saw the shooting schedule for this. Kelly Cantley
埃琳在前台，正隔着隔板看着会计部那边。我觉得她只是觉得他们过得太开心了。我是说，她看着他们的眼神，就像是在看着一场巨大的自助晚宴。带着一种非常渴望的眼神。对啊，她简直就像是入迷了。我看到了这一集的拍摄日程表。凯莉·坎特利
sent it to me and this was the very first thing you guys shot. Oh. And in fact, you shot this whole first webisode basically in order, which is so unusual. Oh yeah, because sometimes we would bounce around. Sure. But that sounds like Kelly, doesn't it? Very efficient. Yes, here it is. She knows how to lay it out. Yeah. Well, you know, I did reach out to Ellie about this, and I sent her the link so she could watch.
把它发给了我，这竟然是你们拍的第一场戏。哦。事实上，你们基本上是按顺序拍完了整整第一集的网络短剧，这太不寻常了。哦，对啊，因为有时候我们会跳着拍。当然。但听起来很像凯莉的风格，对吧？非常高效。没错，就是这样。她很懂得怎么进行统筹。对啊。嗯，你知道的，我确实为此联系了埃丽，我把链接发给了她，好让她看看。
And she said, oh my gosh, Ange, watching that webisode just turned my day around. Thank you. Like five exclamation points. And then she sent in an audio clip. Let's hear it. OK, I loved every webisode for The Office because you got to be a little more, I'll just say, stupid in them. They were pretty silly. I mean, a lot of The Office was silly,
她说：“哦，天哪，安吉，看完那集网络短剧，我一整天的心情都变好了。谢谢。”后面加了五个感叹号。然后她发来了一段音频片段。我们来听听看。好吧，我喜欢《办公室》的每一集网络短剧，因为在里面你可以表现得稍微更……我直说吧，更笨一点。它们挺荒谬的。《办公室》里有很多内容本来就很荒谬，
but these were particularly stupid in a great way. And the mentor was so much fun, Angela, because Angela and I, Angela and Erin didn't always get to have that many scenes together in the show. So it was so wonderful to have a chance to be together in a story. And it's just so ridiculous. The entire getup is insane. Like, Angela, why are you wearing that to work to begin with? And then my like minioning of you, like my copying your outfit, I don't know what I look like but it's not this century and it is bananas. So I remember that the whole webisode was a ton of fun and just stupid and silly. Just overall ridiculous.
但这些短剧特别地傻里傻气，而且效果极佳。安吉拉，《导师》这一集太有趣了，因为在剧中安吉拉和埃琳并不总是有那么多对手戏。所以能有机会在一个故事里合作真的是太棒了。而且这一集简直荒谬透顶。整套行头太疯狂了。安吉拉，你为什么一开始就穿成那样去上班？然后我那种对你的盲目崇拜、对你穿着的模仿——我不知道自己当时看起来像什么样，但绝对不属于这个世纪，简直太荒唐了。所以我记得整集网络短剧拍下来超级好玩，又傻又搞笑。总而言之就是荒诞不经。
And I wouldn't have it any other way. Oh, that's so sweet. I know it did crack me up when she said, I don't know where this outfit is from, but it's not from this century. Well, we'll have to talk about those outfits when we get to them. Well, Erin is going to have a talking head where she says, you know what, sometimes she gets really bored at reception and she wonders what's it like, you know, to have a talking head where she says, you know what, sometimes she gets really bored at reception and she wonders what's it like, you know, to be an accountant, the mystery of the accounting department.
我绝不会希望它有任何改变。哦，太甜了。我知道，当她说“我不知道这套衣服是从哪个世纪弄来的，但绝对不属于这个世纪”时，我真的笑喷了。好吧，等我们聊到那些服装时，我们得好好谈谈。嗯，埃琳有一个单人访谈（Talking Head），她在里面说，你知道吗，有时候她在前台真的觉得很无聊，她很好奇，你知道的，拥有一个单人访谈机会是什么感觉——她在里面说，你知道吗，有时候她在前台真的觉得很无聊，她很好奇，你知道的，当一名会计是什么感觉，会计部门充满了神秘感。
And she goes up to Oscar in the kitchen and she's like, look, I want your life. How do I get it? And then he asks her, is she good with numbers? And she does her impression of the count from Sesame Street. I think we need to hear it. Are you good with numbers, and she does her impression of the Count from Sesame Street. I think we need to hear it. Are you good with numbers? The Count used to be my favorite part of Sesame Street.
然后她走到厨房的奥斯卡旁边说：“听着，我想要你的生活。我该怎么得到它？”接着奥斯卡问她擅不擅长数字，然后她模仿了《芝麻街》里的伯爵（The Count）。我觉得我们得听听这个。你擅长数字吗？然后她模仿了《芝麻街》里的伯爵。我觉得我们得听听这个。你擅长数字吗？伯爵以前是我在《芝麻街》里最喜欢的角色。
One apple, two apples, three apples. Ah, ah, ah, ah. Yeah, maybe it's not for you. All right, first of all, you can see that Ellie is breaking at the end of it. Yes. But secondly, the reason why I wanted to play this clip is that Aaron is not the only person in the office
一个苹果，两个苹果，三个苹果。啊，啊，啊，啊。好吧，也许这不适合你。首先，你可以看到埃丽在最后笑场了。对啊。但其次，我想播放这个片段的原因是，埃琳并不是办公室里唯一一个
that does an impression of the Count from Sesame Street. Yes, there was an office episode. Is it Kevin that does the Count when he's the Girl Scout cookies? Kevin gets made fun of by Oscar as Cookie Monster. Oh yeah. And that clip goes around. And then Kevin tries to make fun of Oscar
模仿《芝麻街》伯爵的人。对啊，有一集《办公室》里。是凯文在分发女童军饼干时模仿了伯爵吗？凯文被奥斯卡嘲笑像饼干怪兽。哦对。那个片段流传很广。然后凯文试图通过把奥斯卡比作伯爵来嘲笑奥斯卡，但奥斯卡在视频里只是用他平常的声音说话。好吧。但真正模仿伯爵的人其实是你。什么？我吗？什么？我们怎么刚刚才重温完整部剧，
by making Oscar the count, but Oscar is just his normal voice in the video. Okay. But the person that does the count impression is you. What? I do? What? How did we just rewatch this whole show
而我完全不记得这个？我当时笑疯了。所以，请欣赏：两人的伯爵模仿秀对决。好吧，我是说，伯爵的声音非常独特。对啊，我想数到十。耶。哇。不管怎样，这把我逗乐了。我们来自圣路易斯的两个姑娘，都在模仿《芝麻街》的伯爵。太搞笑了。
and I don't remember this? And I was cracking up. So here you go, dueling the count impressions. Yeah, I mean, the count has a very distinct voice. Yeah, I want to count to ten. Yes. Wow. Anyway, that cracked me up. Our two gals from St. Louis, both doing the count from Sesame Street. That's very funny.
我不记得这个了？我当时笑疯了。所以给你听听，两个人模仿伯爵（Count）。对啊，我是说，伯爵的声音非常独特。对，我想数到十。是的。哇。总之，这把我逗乐了。我们来自圣路易斯的两个姑娘，都在模仿《芝麻街》里的伯爵。这太搞笑了。
Well, Oscar is gonna tell Erin that he does not think that accounting is for her. Erin's like very dejected, but all of a sudden, Angela, who's sitting at the table in the kitchen, is gonna chime in and say, "'You know what? I'll mentor you.'" But she's so snarky, even in how she offers.
嗯，奥斯卡告诉埃琳，他觉得会计工作不适合她。埃琳看起来非常沮丧，但突然间，坐在厨房桌子旁的安吉拉插话了，说道：“你知道吗？我来当你的导师。”但她说得极其刻薄，就连提出帮忙时也是如此。
She's like, I mean, I'll do it. I do everything else around here. Yeah. She's so put out. I love it. But she'll do this project. You have a great talking head, Angela, where you say you see potential in her.
她就像是：我是说，我来吧。这里的所有事都是我在做。对啊。她觉得自己受委屈了。我太喜欢了。但她还是会接手这个项目。安吉拉，你有一个很棒的单人访谈，你在里面说你在她身上看到了潜力。
Right now, there's nothing. There's nothing. But there could be some potential. Well right away, Angela starts training Erin in the art of sealing an envelope. Yeah. I guess you don't do that at front reception. You're going to learn how to do it over in accounting. So you guys know I had a very hard time saying self-sealed.
目前来看，什么都没有。什么都没有。但可能会有一些潜力。好吧，安吉拉马上开始在信封封装的艺术上培训埃琳。对啊。我猜你在前台不干这个。你得去会计部学习怎么做。所以大家知道，我在说“自粘”（self-sealed）这个词时遇到了很大的困难。
Self-sealed. Self-sealed. Self-sealed. Self-sealed. There it is. There it is. That Self-sealed. Self-sealed. There it is. There it is. That's what I had to do on the day.
自粘。自粘。自粘。自粘。自粘。就是这样。就是这样。自粘。自粘。就是这样。就是这样。那是我当时拍那一幕时必须要经历的。
But it's a vowel before an L. My Southern folks out there, do you struggle with that? Angela goes on to say, you know, licking is for idiots. That means you, Kevin. Kevin likes how they taste. I bet he does. I have a question. Do you lick envelopes?
但那是一个元音接在L音前面。我那些南方的朋友们，你们对这个发音感到纠结吗？安吉拉接着说，你知道的，“舔信封是笨蛋干的事”。“那就是在说你，凯文。”凯文挺喜欢那种味道的。我敢打赌他确实喜欢。我有个问题。你们会舔信封吗？
Not if I can help it. I don't like the taste. When I worked in an office, I had to do a lot of mass mailings. Mm-hmm. Like a lot. Yeah, we did too. When I worked at 1-800-Dennis, we sent out a company Christmas card. Hundreds.
能避免的话我尽量不舔。我不喜欢那个味道。我以前在办公室工作时，得做大量的群发邮件。嗯哼。比如很多。对，我们也是。我以前在1-800-Dennis工作时，我们寄出了公司的圣诞卡。几百张。
Oh, this was like, I would have to send out for whatever reason, like marketing things or like sales charts or like, I don't even know. So many mass mailings. I guess that today are just emails? Probably. Okay. Well. Newsletters. Yeah. And the emails.
哦，这就像是——不管出于什么原因，我得寄出一些营销资料、或者销售图表之类的东西，或者我甚至都不知道是什么。太多的群发信件了。我猜现在的群发都变成电子邮件了吧？大概吧。好吧。通讯简报。对啊。还有电子邮件。
Well, I would get one of those things that like holds water. It's like a mini- Adobber. Yeah. And then that's what I would do to seal my envelopes. Are you ready for this? What? They had a machine that you loaded the envelope in and it went through the machine. A liquor machine?
嗯，我会用那种可以装水的工具。就像是一个迷你的……小海绵涂抹器。对啊。然后那就是我用来封装信封的工具。你准备好听这个了吗？什么？他们有一种机器，你把信封放进去，它就会通过机器自动处理。是舔信封机吗？
A liquor machine. Like it would lick it? Yeah, you just ran it through and it wouldn't moist. And then you seal it and you run it through and seal it. Well, my office didn't have that fancy machine. Maybe you should get one. You know what this is reminding me of?
舔信封机。就像它会帮你舔一样？对，你只要把信封塞进去，它就会弄湿。然后你把它封好，再塞进去封口。好吧，我的办公室可没有那种高级机器。也许你应该买一台。你知不知道这让我想起了什么？
What? One time I was a temp at a health care company, like an insurance place. Oh, yeah? And my boss went on vacation, and she, like, showed me. Before she went on vacation, I was, like, supposed to watch her desk or whatever. Mm-hmm.
什么？有一次我在一家医疗公司打临时工，类似于一家保险公司。哦，是吗？然后我的老板去度假了，她，呃，给我交代了工作。在她去度假之前，我得，呃，看着她的办公桌还是什么的。嗯哼。
And her job had something to do with, like, giving people coverage or not giving them coverage. Oh my god. And I was supposed to like look up stuff on a chart. Determine if they got coverage or not. Yeah, for whatever their thing was. And I found it confusing. And I also just didn't have it in me to not cover things. So for one week, I covered everybody's s***. And I don't even know whatever happened. I don't know if my boss came back and was like, what the hell? Oh, because you just tipped the week she was gone?
而她的工作跟什么有关呢，比如决定给人们提供医疗保险还是不提供。哦天哪。然后我得像查表一样去查找资料。判定他们是否享有医保。对，不管他们办的是什么业务。我觉得这很让人困惑。而且我当时也没有那个铁石心肠去拒绝给别人提供保障。所以在一个星期里，我给所有人的狗屁事情都批了保障。而且我甚至不知道后来发生了什么。我不知道我的老板回来后有没有说“这到底是怎么回事？”哦，因为你就在她不在的那一个星期里大开绿灯？
Yeah, for one week. Oh my gosh. And it was like an automated system, but I had to like enter a code. And I had to like code it. And then I had to say like, I just had to hit a button that was like covered or not covered. And so for one week under her code, I just had to hit a button that was like covered or not covered. And so for one week under her code, I just covered everybody's stuff.
对，就一个星期。哦，天哪。那是一个自动化系统，但我得输入一个代码。我得像写代码一样操作它。然后我必须说——我只需要按一个按钮，上面写着“已承保”或“未承保”。所以在一个星期里，在她的代码权限下，我只需要按一个按钮，显示“已承保”或“未承保”。所以在一个星期里，在她的代码权限下，我只是给所有人的事情都批准了保障。
Wow. Everybody got coverage the week I was a temp. I feel like it's such a, I would think, a big responsibility to just like leave to someone you don't know at all, who hasn't learned your job. She was a big executive. I thought it was so bizarre.
哇。我当临时工的那一个星期，每个人都得到了医保。我觉得这真的是——我会觉得，把这么大的责任随便留给一个你根本不认识、也完全没学过你工作的人，这太不可思议了。她是个大高管。我觉得这太离谱了。
I'm thrilled that everyone got covered. I mean. I know. I was bizarre. I'm thrilled that everyone got covered. I know. I was like, I don't work here. I barely understand these forms. I have to put covered or not covered because if you're gonna put that in my hands, everyone's covered because God forbid I don't cover something that shouldn't be covered.
我很高兴每个人都得到了保障。我是说。我知道。这太离谱了。我很高兴每个人都得到了保障。我知道。我当时就想：我又不在这里上班。我根本看不懂这些表格。我必须勾选“已承保”或“未承保”，因为如果你把这个权力交到我手上，那所有人都有保障，因为我可担不起“不小心漏掉了本该承保的项目”这种责任。
I'd rather err the other way. And you know, it's on you, big company. But I mean, it's like paid, paid, paid, paid. Just paid them. Wow. It's like you get paid, you get paid, you get it. Here's your coverage. But also, ever since I worked there, I've thought about just how incredibly random,
我宁愿走向另一个极端。而且你知道的，这是你们大公司自己的事。但我的意思是，付钱，付钱，付钱，付钱。直接给他们付钱。哇。就好像你拿到了钱，你拿到了钱，你拿到了。这是给你的保障。而且，自从我在那里工作过之后，我一直在想，这种事情是多么的随心所欲、难以预测，
like hit me on a good day, you're covered. Hit me on a day that I feel like I have to go by the quote-unquote rules, you're not covered. Like, it was so impersonal. Yeah, and these are people's lives. Yes! And they're healthcare. Yeah. And it's always left an impression on me. Yeah, how could it not?
遇到我心情好的一天，你就获得了保障。遇到我觉得必须按所谓的规矩办事的一天，你就没有保障。这真的是太冷血、太不讲人情了。对啊，这可是人命关天的事。没错！这关乎医疗健康。对啊。而且这一直在我的脑海里留下了深刻的印象。对啊，怎么可能不深刻呢？
Right? Yeah. I know. Oh, man. That bums me out. I'm so sorry. It's okay. This is a story from your life. It's just that bums me out. I'm so sorry. It's okay. This is a story from your life. It's just a story from my life.
对吧？对啊。我知道。噢，天哪。这让我有点沮丧。我很抱歉。没关系。这是你生活中的一个故事。只是这让我有点沮丧。我很抱歉。没关系。这只是我生活中的一个故事。
These things happen. Also at that job I had to do a mass mailing. And they didn't have a licky machine I bet. They didn't. Well, Erin. Where are we? Well, we're in the conference room. Angela is showing Erin how to do her makeup.
这种事总是会发生。还有，在那份工作里我也得做群发邮件。我敢打赌他们没有舔信封机。他们确实没有。好吧，埃琳。我们现在在哪？好吧，我们在会议室里。安吉拉正在教埃琳怎么化妆。
She wipes Erin's mascara off. She says, listen, if a fleck of this were to fall onto the ledger, it could look like a decimal point. And that's a thousand dollar mistake. I know we just went off topic, but I was going to tell this story and it's so embarrassing. But I just went to the dermatologist for her to look at my rosacea. Sure. With that super high powered, it's like, it looks like a little wand they hold up
她擦掉了埃琳脸上的睫毛膏。她说：“听着，如果这上面哪怕有一小片掉到账本上，它看起来都可能像是一个小数点。那可就是一千美元的失误。”我知道我们刚才扯远了，但我正打算讲这个故事，而且真的超级尴尬。我刚刚去皮肤科医生那里看我的红斑痤疮。当然。用那种超高倍数的——就好像，看起来像是一个他们举着的小魔杖，
and then it flashes your face on the computer, like the pigmentation. Okay. And so it shows your pigmentation super like magnified. Right? And you know, cause I have rosacea, it's like red, red, red. And then all of a sudden there was like these two black dots.
然后把你的脸部情况投影到电脑屏幕上，比如色素沉着。好吧。所以它会把你的色素沉着放大得超级清晰。对吧？而且你知道，因为我有红斑痤疮，所以看起来红、红、红。然后突然之间，出现了两个黑点。
And I go, oh. I go, sorry, I guess my face is also dirty. I should have washed it, you know, trying to make a joke. And she goes, no, those are probably hairs. Wait, what? You were thinking they were mascara slacks. Yes. And she's like, no, you have two tiny black hairs growing out
我说，哦。我说，“对不起，我猜我的脸也挺脏的。我本该洗个脸的，”我试图开个玩笑。然后她说：“不，那可能是毛发。”等等，什么？你以为那是睫毛膏碎屑。对啊。然后她说：“不，你的脸颊上长了两根细小的黑毛。”
of your cheek. And I said, that is horrifying. And she was, no, it happens. It's perfectly normal. So. Hashtag, burial menopause. I hope you guys are still listening. This happens.
我说：“这太可怕了。”她说：“不，这很正常。完全是正常现象。”所以。话题标签，更年期。我希望你们还在听。这很正常。
It happens. Hairs grow out of your face when you get older. All right, listen, we're going to talk about the mentor now. Okay. Here's what's happening. Erin is now transformed into Angela. She is wearing the same sort of like high neck, white blouse. With so many buttons.
人老了脸上就会长毛。好了，听着，我们现在要来聊聊《导师》了。好吧。接下来发生的是：埃琳现在变成了安吉拉的化身。她穿着那种高领的白色衬衫。上面有超多的纽扣。
Very Victorian looking. Angela has sawed off Erin's high heels. Yep. And they walk into the break room together in sync. They're like just two little marching people walking in saying, hey, expense reports are due by lunch, no late exceptions, no excuses, Meredith. And they turn and walk out.
看起来非常维多利亚风格。安吉拉锯短了埃琳的高跟鞋。没错。然后她们迈着同步的步伐一起走进了休息室。她们就像是两个小步兵一样走进去说：“嘿，费用报销单在午餐前必须交齐，没有迟交的例外，也没有任何借口，梅雷迪斯。”然后她们转身走了出去。
I think she's even walking like you. She's dressed like you, she's got the braid like you. And she is starting to mimic your physicality as she walks out of the conference room. I do remember Ellie, like, looking at me, like we were on set and I was sitting. And I was like, what are you doing? And she was like, I'm trying to sit like you. Yeah, I could tell.
我觉得她甚至连走路的姿势都跟你一样。她穿得像你，扎着跟你一样的辫子。而且她开始模仿你走出会议室时的身体姿态。我确实记得埃丽看着我——就像我们在片场时我正坐着。然后我问：“你在干嘛？”她说：“我在学你怎么坐。”对啊，我看得出来。
All right, that ends webisode number one. Part two is titled, Reimbursements. And I wanted to share some more from Kelly Cantley. Okay, great. About her directing. She said she really prepped the hell out of this. I believe that. You sort of mentioned that she knew exactly
好了，第一集网络短剧到此结束。第二部分标题是《报销》。我想分享更多来自凯莉·坎特利的内容。好的，太棒了。关于她的导演工作。她说她为这一幕做了百分之两百的准备。我完全相信。你刚刚也提到了，她确切地知道
what she wanted to do. She said that she bugged Randall Einhorn every day at lunch or wrap for about a week talking to him about how she was planning to shoot this. Because she said this was 11 pages of material and you had one 11-hour day including lunch to get all this work done. I looked at the schedule and you shot this on Monday October 19th 2009 which means it would have been during our sixth season of the show. I remember we were on hiatus that October because Steve was
doing a movie. Kelly said that on the shooting day you guys would rehearse and then Randall would give, like, grip and electric lighting notes. And then while they were lighting the scene you just rehearsed, her and Randall would run to the next scene and prep that. And that's how you guys... Kept going? Yeah, she said it was really hectic, but it was a lot of fun.
She said she could have never done it without Randall's support. And she also wants to give a big thank you to Paul Lieberstein and Steve Burgess, who gave her the chance to direct. Well, this second episode of the webisode is going to open with an Angela and Erin talking head. Yeah, this talking head is going to reveal why the whole office isn't there. Apparently Michael took everyone out to spaghetti Eddie's and a lot of them got food poisoning. But I also do love that in this joint talking head,
they are starting to sit alike and their mannerisms are becoming more alike. And I imagine Kelly, as the director, was really happy that they wrote this talking head because it meant she didn't have to just have certain angles that didn't show the whole bullpen. Which we had done in other webisodes and it made it difficult.
So adding that one little story piece, now she can show the whole bullpen. That's right. Well, next up, Erin is going to start passing out reimbursement checks. Meredith notices hers is short and Erin kind of feels bad and kind of starts being like, well, Angela is behind her and goes, ahem, ahem. And then that's when Erin is like, hey, we only reimburse up to 30 days and your receipts are 32 days old.
Meredith is pissed. She says, how am I supposed to get the boot off my car now? Yeah, when I saw this part, I was like, what is Meredith's job again? Why is she getting reimbursement checks? Client services? I went to the show Bible and she is service rep slash supplier relations. Oh, right.
Supplier relations. Yeah. Remember she was sleeping with the one guy from the free paper or something paper and then there was steak involved. Yeah. But yeah, so I could see her like taking suppliers out to lunch. Yeah. To a boozy lunch.
Sure. And then she has to a boozy lunch. And then she has to get reimbursed. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Erin and Angela now walk into the kitchen and Erin's like, that was such an adrenaline rush. And Angela's like, you did great in there.
Angela's so tickled. And they walk past Creed and Erin says, hey, we don't reimburse for Rhino Horn, as it's not work related. And then I have a little bit of an improv. Uh-huh. Is this when you tell Creed to shower? Yeah. I say you need to shower and shave. So if you look, Creed is not shaved in this episode. Well, I mean, it was our week off.
It was his week off. And so we had sort of like given him crap about it between scenes, and so I improvised it in the episode. Oh, that's very funny. Yeah. Well, I deep dived Rhino horn. What? Should you be interested?
Why is Creed getting Rhino horn? Why is he? Well, according to worldwildlife.org, for centuries Rhino horn has been used in traditional Chinese medicine to treat a wide variety of illnesses ranging from reducing fevers to stopping nosebleeds and preventing strokes. My internet AI search, because now if you Google something,
you get like that weird AI compilation of... Of like suggestions of what it could be. Yeah, so rather than showing me all the articles for me to click on, it does like that little AI summary. I don't know, do I trust it? I don't know, I like to read the articles, but full disclosure, that little summary thing said that some people also believe
that rhino horn is an aphrodisiac, and some black market dealers claim it can cure cancer, but there is no scientific proof that it can cure anything. Yeah, so leave the rhinos alone. It's a problem. Yeah. ScientificAmerican.com confirms that Rhino Horn has been used historically in traditional Chinese medicine. The list of historical uses also includes headaches, hallucinations, high blood pressure, typhoid, snakebite, food poisoning, and even possession by spirits.
Stop it. Leave them alone. However, the president of the American College of Chinese Medicine said, every historical documented use of rhino horn in traditional Chinese medicine was for treating conditions such as fever and infection. It was never used to improve sexual function or to cure cancer. So it was used, but very sparingly, but a lot of black market dealers claimed that it can do all kinds of things.
So what Creed was using it for or what he wanted it for, I don't know, but leave the rhinos alone. Don't buy this. There are so many websites where like, please don't buy this item because you know. They kill the rhinos. They kill the rhino just for the horn. Yeah, it's horrible.
It's not good. Well, now Erin is gonna have maybe the toughest person to give her bad news to. She's gonna go up to Kelly and Ryan in the annex and she gives Ryan his check. And then she turns to Kelly and says, listen, you can't get reimbursed for your business dinners. And Kelly's like, what?
She goes, we didn't talk about business on those dinners. Rules are rules. Kelly is ticked off. And Ryan is like enjoying it. He's like, drama. Yeah. And then Kelly has a talking head that's basically just her being like, Angela, Angela.
I get sent that. You do? Yeah. It's online and I've been sent it before. Well Kelly is not seeing Angela as a proper mentor for Erin. This is where we end this episode and in the next episode Kelly is going to take matters into her own hands. Part three is titled Lunchtime.
Kelly and Ryan are going to approach Erin at reception and they say, hey, we're going to go to Farley's for lunch and we'd love for you to join. And she was like, yes, I'd love to. Yes. And then Ryan says, Kelly, go get your wallet. I'm ready to go. Such a turd. I know. Angela is watching all of this and she does not want Erin to go with them for lunch. And so she says, hey, Erin, do you want to have lunch?
And over lunch, we can go through invoices. Yeah, she says, maybe we'll even use the Kohler method. And Erin's like, what's that? And she was like, it's accounting. Would you like to learn it? And she's like, I would very much like to learn it. And Angela's like, great, we can share my Fig Newton. I have a question for you.
Were you curious if the Kohler method was real or made up? I was. What do you think? Real. It is real. It is. So this guy, Eric Lewis Kohler, was an American accountant. And he wrote the Dictionary of Accounting,
the show Bible of accounting that is used to this day. To this day? Yes! His dictionary is considered the comprehensive resource for understanding accounting terminology and principles. It covers a wide range of accounting topics, including auditing, cost accounting, and financial accounting. It is the show bible of accounting.
Wow. Mm-hmm. He wrote it way back then. We're still using it. Yeah. Wow. Mm-hmm. He wrote it way back then and we're still using it. That's some old tech. It's old academia. There you go. Right? You did it.
I did it. You did it. Well, Kelly and Ryan are ready to go. I guess Kelly went and got her wallet and Erin is going to say, I can't go. And then Kelly's like, what? And starts to bribe her. Like, do you want these earrings? You know, they're yours.
Would you like to have them back? And then Angela's like, I have triple carbon invoices. And they're kind of doing this back and forth. Kelly's like, you can write in the front seat. And Angela says, her earrings have depreciated. Would you like to know what that means? She's like, I would very much like to know what that means. I have to say this, I actually am bummed that Kelly isn't
supporting Erin in this moment because Erin clearly wants to learn some stuff. Well, Kelly's not a real friend. I know. Why am I even going there? Ultimately, Erin does not go with Ryan and Kelly. Kelly is still so ticked. She's like, Angela, seriously? And they leave. And Angela's just so tickled.
Yeah, this episode is gonna end with Erin telling Creed that he is also not gonna be reimbursed for buying a monkey paw. Please tell me you didn't look up monkey paw on the black market. You know that I did. Why? Well, why would he have one?
Well, he's clearly like dealing in some black market trade ring now. Okay, well, I thought, is this medicinal? You know, no. Here's what I could find. The Monkey's Paw was a horror short story by English author, WW Jacobs. It first appeared in Harper's Monthly in September 1902.
And here's what happens in the story. Three wishes are granted to the owner of the monkey's paw, but the wishes come with an enormous price for interfering with fate. Also, the 1983 novel Pet Sematary by Stephen King was reportedly inspired by The Monkey Paw. I mean, Pet Sematary is so scary. Yeah, I read it a long, long time ago. I watched part of it and couldn't finish it. It was too creepy.
Well, lady, you don't like horror stuff. I do not. But... Don't say it. We have an episode coming up where you have agreed to watch the first 15 minutes. 15 minutes. To 20, because I picked a movie and I'm going to need 22 minutes of your time. All right, you watched 30 minutes of John Wick? At least. I might have watched close to 45, honestly. I don't know when he gets the adrenaline shot from the doctor, but that's how far I watched.
It's pretty far. Okay. I got to the whole rave. But anyway. The assassin's rave? I've picked the movie for you. You have? And I watched the first 22 minutes,
and it's gonna be very intense, but it's not gonna be, I cut out before like the mega gory stuff. Gory? So it's not just like suspense horror, it's like gory stuff? Mm-hmm. Oh God, I'm not gonna like it.
Are you gonna tell me the name of the movie or are you saving that for a reveal? Want me to tell you now? John Carpenter's The Thing, starring Kurt Russell. Is The Thing something out of a swamp? I'm not gonna tell you. God. Uh, Sam is thumbs-upping my choice.
Okay. You're gonna love it, Angela. Is she? But... Yes. Yes, you are. It's such a... It's a classic. It's a great film. It's like a truly great film.
You know what I'll do is I'll have Josh film me as I watch the 22 minutes. Perfect. All right, well, we should point out that that webisode also has a Kevin talking head where he says, what does depreciate mean? Yeah. How does he not know that?
I wanna save that for this next webisode because it's gonna come up later for me. We are onto part four titled BFFs? Question mark? Question mark. Yeah, this webisode starts with Erin, she's walking in the kitchen, she actually walks up to Creed,
and right as she does, that little, I don't know, what is it, a janitor's closet that Ryan has made his office, the door opens up and he grabs Erin and pulls her in and shuts the door. Yes. Creed doesn't even raise an eyebrow. Yes.
It just goes about his day. This is when Kelly is gonna force Erin to watch a slideshow of all of the fun times they've had together. It's pictures of the two of them together. Kelly is complimenting herself a lot, how cute she looks. Look at how cute I am in this one. It's very funny. This slides complimenting herself a lot. How cute she looks. Look at how cute I am in this one. It's very funny.
This slideshow is all about Kelly. It has nothing to do with them being good friends. No, Erin happens to be in the pictures. And she gives Erin an ultimatum. I love this line. She says, are we going to be BFFs or just Fs? And that would be pretty F-ing awful. Erin is going to admit that they did have some good times. Ryan tries to pull them in for a group hug. So we also learned during the scene, because Ryan has a talking head, that he's been laying the groundwork for a threesome.
He thinks he's about a week away. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Lady, I'm sorry to tell you I am having a hot flash. Okay. I need air. You look a little sweaty. Well, I am sweaty.
Yes. As happens with a hot flash. Would everyone be okay if we just took a break? I'll cool down a little sweaty. Well, I am sweaty. Yes. As happens with a hot flash. Would everyone be OK if we just took a break? I'll cool down a little. Mm-hmm. We'll come back. I'm going to have some cheese. OK.
Then we'll finish breaking down this last webisode, and we'll also get into our mentorship stories. How does that sound? Sounds great. I have a thing when we come back I'm calling wig gate. Oh, okay. This is it. The day you finally ask for that big promotion. You're in front of your mirror with your Starbucks coffee.
Then we'll finish breaking down this last webisode, and we'll also get into our mentorship stories. How does that sounds? Sounds great. I have a thing when we come back I'm calling wig gate. Oh, okay. This is it. The day you finally ask for that big promotion. You're in front of your mirror with your Starbucks coffee.
Be confident. Assertive. Remember eye contact. But also, remember to blink. Smile. But not too much. That's weird. What if you aren't any good at your job? What if they demote you instead? Okay, don't be silly. You're smart. You're driven. You're gonna be late if you keep talking to the mirror. This promotion is yours. Go get them. Starbucks. It's never just coffee. All right, we're back and I just want to give everyone an update that It's never just coffee. [♪THEME MUSIC PLAYING Alright, we're back. And I just want to give everyone an update that my hot flash has passed. I'm sure I'll get another one before the end of the podcast.
I'm getting these because I'm on tamoxifen, which it suppresses by estrogen absorption. It is for part of my breast cancer treatment. This is an ongoing thing. I have to take it for five years. And hot flashes are a side effect. I'm basically like a woman white-knuckling her way through menopause because I'm allowed no support because... That's horrible. I know.
That's horrible. I know. All I'm allowed to do is like have fans and like drink cold water. I can't take anything. But let me end on an up, my eye's feeling better. Oh, yeah. Well, that's good. So I don't think I need to go to an eye doctor today. Oh, that's a relief.
It is. Now where were we? Oh yes, Angela and Erin are sitting side by side. They're working together. But Erin's gonna have a talking head where she says, you know what, both Kelly and Erin are her friends. She feels really conflicted. Yeah, she's torn.
She is. Isn't this wig gate? This is wig gate for me. All right. I know this sounds crazy, but if you go to a minute and 23 seconds, her bangs look different. Something is different.
Erin's bangs? Yes, and I'm like, what happened? I actually texted Ellie, but she hasn't gotten back to me yet because I'm like, Ellie, don't think I'm crazy. Is there any world where you would have needed to warn a wig one day? It's only in two talking heads. I know, but you shot this all in the same day. I know.
Why would she have had regular hair earlier in the shooting and then suddenly be in a wig? All I can think of is we broke for lunch and maybe whoever had done her hair left for the day. It's different. It is different. Look, I took pictures. I need you to look at this.
I looked at the schedule. There were no pickups. You did this all in one day. That's fine. Fine. I am telling you, whoever did her hair left and then they had to redo it, maybe she took a nap at lunch. I want you to look at her hair.
Look at her bangs line. Look at her bangs. Okay. Okay, I'm coming over to you. I mean, you have your glasses on, but you're across the table. I'm coming over. Okay, now we're together on one microphone.
Okay, I see it. This is how she looks the whole entire episode. Okay. Okay. Yep. And then in this talking head, it's somewhere. Oh, look at that. What? See? Wait, I don't think those are her real bangs.
I know. I think those are clip-on bangs. Yes. What is this? Yeah. Oh, lady, you have done it. I know. I know. What the heck is that?
That's a mom detective right there. I know, and I texted Ellie, and as soon as she gets back to me about it, I'm gonna share. Even if it's in another episode, I'm gonna be like, you guys remember the wig gate and the mentor? I bought fakey clip-on bangs when I lost my hair. Even if it's in another episode, I'm gonna be like, you guys remember the wig gate and the mentor?
I bought fakie clip-on bangs when I lost my hair. Because I wondered if I could kind of put them in, like on the little bit of sprig of hair that I had left. I know a clip-on bang when I see it. By the way, the answer was no, because they were all awful. But that is a fakie bang. I know, look at the line of it. that is a fakey bang. I know. Look at the line of it.
It's a fakey bang. I know. And you know what they do is they do a thing, because I've had on a show one time, they tried to give me bangs and I didn't have bangs. They pull some of your hair down and then they clip under it. That's right. And she has this overlap.
Yes, she does. So I don't know if that was a pickup that we did and she had grown her bangs out. I don't know. Listen, something happened. You did it. You uncovered that. Okay. I give that all to you.
Thank you. Well, now Erin is gonna unbutton her blouse a little bit in front of Angela. Yeah. This is her way, I guess, of like reclaiming a little bit in front of Angela. This is her way, I guess, of reclaiming a little bit of herself. Oh, Angela is not having it. Yeah, and then she's like, just stop.
And then Erin tells Angela she rounded down rather than up, that Angela has made a mistake. And Angela says, get out. Talk about no wiggle room for forgiveness. And this is when Kevin offers to be Erin's mentor. This is when I would like to call back the Kevin talking head where he doesn't know what depreciate means. Yeah, I'm not so sure he's the best mentor for Erin. Not that Angela was great, but she was actually learning things from
Angela. Yes, because now we're going to learn that Kevin makes a lot of errors even with his adding machine. So Kevin and Erin are now in the kitchen. He's teaching her how to be an accountant. He's showing her how to use the adding machine. She's kind of heavy-handed with it. So he takes over and she just starts reading him numbers. He's entering the numbers, entering the numbers. He's doing it like without even looking at the counting machine. Yeah. His fingers are just like going over the keys
And she's like that's amazing and I know some people can really do that. Mm-hmm, but Kevin says yeah, it's a gift 70% accuracy. Yeah lady 70% accuracy that means 30% of the time he's wrong. Yeah, he's just made nonsense That's not good. That's not good. No. Well, this made me think of a letter that we got. It cracked me up.
It is from Claire F. in Brisbane, Australia. She wrote in and said, "'A friend and colleague of mine, let's call her Kate, is a music-" Oh, I love any letter that's like, let's call her. Go on. "'Let's call her Kate, is a music teacher, specifically band and woodwind instruments, okay?
When our department got a new manager, she put in parentheses, let's call him Ron. Okay. I love it, I love a code name, Claire. She said, we all figured out that Ron really didn't know what he was doing quite quickly. One day he called Kate into his office and said that he had been impressed by her work, and seeing as she is young and still relatively a new teacher, would she like to have him,
Ron, as her mentor? Kate was hesitant, but what could she say to her boss? So she agreed, and so began a series of patronizing and unhelpful meetings and rehearsal observations. The mentorship came to a swift end when Ron offered Kate a lesson on oboes, an instrument he does not play. Claire shares with us that oboes are notoriously hard to play
due to the type of reed they use. There is an incredible amount of back pressure when you blow into it. Ron started the oboe lesson with Kate. He blew into the oboe, made a quick sound, then stopped abruptly with a grunt. He left the room in a hurry and did not return. Had he pooped himself? What happened?
It turns out that when Ron blew into the oboe, the back pressure had been so much that he'd given himself a hernia. Oh! Oh! And then Claire says, that was the end of that. Oh my goodness. So I just had to share that because I was like, this is the example of not being a great mentor. Yes, for sure. Thank you, Claire, for writing in.
Ah. Kelly is now going to burst into the kitchen crying. She said her sister was named prom queen. This is obviously really upset her. Erin looks to Kevin like, what do I do? Kevin says, go to her. Go comfort her. And she gets up and they embrace.
And Kevin has a talking head where he says, she's going to blossom under his tutelage. Yeah, and then Oscar has a snarky talking head where he just says, yeah, Kevin can be a great teacher if you want to learn how to eat pizza. Mm-hmm, geez, Oscar. Why'd you even have to chime in, bud? Just to be a snark.
Just to be a snarky snark. Erin is going to end this webisode series with a talking head. I want you to know, Fakie Bangs are back. Okay. Two minutes, 53 seconds. All right. She says you can have it all. Be BFFs with Kelly and Crunch Numbers.
She's one lucky duck. Okay. All right. So she got her friendship back with Kelly because she soothed Kelly through this drama with her sister becoming prom queen. And she gets to be an accountant because now Kevin is her mentor. So I guess that's her win-win-win. Oh wait, Ellie just texted me back.
What did she say? Is it an answer? She put in all caps, look, absolute wig, right? What? And then she has like four question marks and then she says, I have no memory of a wig one way or the other, but those bangs. I mean, what was going on? And why would I need a wig?
It's so confusing. Didn't I have bangs already? Was the wig for the French braid? Literally, what is the situation? So she has no memory, but is also confirming that it is a wig. Oh yeah, she said it's absolutely a wig, but I can't remember why.
Well, there you go. Mystery solved? Ish. We may never know. We may never know. That's kind of our thing. Well, this whole mentor webisode did remind me of a letter that we got from Katie M. in
Richmond, Virginia that I wanted to read because it's about women helping women in business. Okay. Because that's what this is. Yeah. Angela's helping another woman in business. Katie said, I've been working at my company for five years and roughly two years in, I started working with a young woman who was about five years older than me, and she very quickly became my work BFF.
We tackled many projects together and also made it through some rough times from sexist coworkers to surviving a series of layoffs. After a big restructuring, she ended up being on another team, and while we knew we wouldn't be able to work together as much, we still made an effort to have a long chat at least once a month. It was through these chats that we began talking seriously about career trajectories, and she inspired me
into taking on more serious projects on my team and advocating for myself. At the end of last year, a position opened up on her new team, and she went above and beyond in helping me prepare for interviews, market myself, and boost my confidence. Because of her, I ended up getting a serious promotion, and I am now directly in the field I want to be.
Because of her, for the first time in my professional career, I am on an incredible team of all women. Let's break the narrative of women kicking the ladder down and promote stories like mine of women lifting each other up. Aw, that's great. I loved that. Thank you, Katie. And you know who it made me think of was Terry Weinberg.
Oh, yes. Terry Weinberg was one of the executive producers on The Office. She worked for Reveille, which was the company that owned the rights to the British office. And they were part of developing the show for an American audience from the very beginning. Terry was part of our auditions.
She was on the set of the pilot. She is just an amazing woman. And after the office was over, and I wanted to maybe get into some producing myself, I had gotten a script and I didn't know where to start. I really liked it. It was from a writer submitted it to me and I thought, how do I get this into the hands of the studios?
Like how do I try to sell this? Right. And I called Terry and Terry said, send it to me. I'll read it. Let's have lunch. I mean, do you know how much she's so busy and like that she took the time to read this thing that I thought maybe I could do something with. She had lunch with me, she gave me all her thoughts. She laid out like, here's what I would do,
here's what I wouldn't do. And I ended up selling it to Warner Brothers. Now the show didn't get made, but under Terry's guidance, like, and she said, always call me about stuff like this, Jenna, always. This is what I do. This is what I love doing.
I love helping other women in this industry make their mark. Yeah. Yeah, she has been incredibly supportive to us over all these years, is still in touch with us, is still such a huge champion. Whatever marker happens in our career, she celebrates it. When we wrote our book, when we got the podcast, just on and on. I'm sure if you look in our comments on Instagram, you're going to see cheerleading from Terry
in our posts. Yeah. She's the best. Yeah. Well, listen, that ends the Webisode series. It was such a pleasure to watch. It was, it was really fun. But before we go, we wanted to share a few more of your stories of mentorship and our own. I'm going to kick us off with a letter that I just loved. It's from Kristen from Virginia. And Kristen says,
When I was in my mid-twenties, I became infatuated with calligraphy. I received a gift certificate to take classes infatuated with calligraphy. I received a gift certificate to take classes with a local woman named Betsy. She was probably in her 70s and was left-handed, which is a challenge for calligraphers. So she wrote upside down. It was incredible to watch. Wow. Yeah.
She was so thrilled someone under the age of 50 actually wanted to learn calligraphy. I was hooked on the art for my very first class with her. I signed up for every class she offered and eventually asked her to be my mentor. I started taking private lessons and she exposed me to so much about the art, different tools and supplies, lettering styles, artists, historical references, and so much more. I learned something new every week, and it really put me ahead when I started engaging in professional work and networking. Because of her, I started a business, wrote a book, started teaching, and became very involved with a professional
calligraphy organization, of which I am currently the president. Wow! I know! In 2020, Betsy was diagnosed with advanced ALS and was unable to continue working. Shortly before she passed away, she referred a few jobs to me and told me that I was one of her best students. And Kristen put in parentheses, crying. I am crying.
Yeah. Chills. She goes on to say she wished me the best of luck with the calligraphy community. This year I got to host a calligraphy conference in the very city she taught me in and it's a really beautiful full circle moment for me. I wouldn't be where I am today without Betsy. I think of Betsy often and how selfless she was. She had no secrets, she just wanted to pass along her knowledge. The style she taught me called copper plate is actually a style she didn't love love,
but she taught it in memory of a dear friend of hers that passed away. The mindset of generosity and legacy is something I carry with me daily. That's making me tear up. Yeah, me too. Betsy was and continues to be an inspiration to me, and I'm so lucky I had the chance to learn from her.
Thanks for the opportunity to share about this mentorship experience that means so much to me." I just love- Is that wonderful? That legacy that Betsy has that she passed down. Yeah, thank you. She changed that woman's life, truly. Truly.
It's become her whole career now. Like. And just took such time to share her knowledge and didn't hold any of it back. Gave it all freely to her, to share with her, to build her up. Kristin, thank you so much for sharing. That letter really touched us
这现在成了她全部的职业。就像。而且花那么多时间分享她的知识，毫无保留。全心全意地奉献给她，与她分享，成就她。克里斯汀，非常感谢你的分享。那封信真的触动了我们
and we're so happy now to know about Betsy. Yeah. Angela, do you want to share about a mentor you've had in your life? Yes. We both decided we wanted to share for this episode about someone who meant a lot to us and mentored us. And I just knew immediately who I was going to share about.
现在我们很高兴能认识贝茜。是的。安吉拉，你想分享一下你生命中的一位导师吗？是的。我们俩都决定在这期节目中分享一个对我们意义重大并指导过我们的人。我立刻就知道我要分享谁了。
And it's my grandmother, Lena Mae Kinsey. So much of who I am, of my values, of the things that I connect with that mean something to me, they all started with her. I've shared this before. I moved around a lot as a kid, just with my dad's job, but my grandmother's home was the one constant place I had. And I would go and stay with her in the summers
那就是我的祖母，莉娜·梅·金西。我的个性、我的价值观、我所接触到对我有意义的事物，很大程度上都始于她。我以前分享过。我小时候经常搬家，因为我爸爸的工作，但祖母的家是我唯一恒久不变的地方。夏天我会去她那里住
and looking back on that time, oh my gosh, I just cherish it. She just taught me so many things. I mean, I started to list them out in no particular order. She taught me how to work a riding lawnmower. She taught me how to drive a car. She taught me how to crochet. She. She taught me how to crochet. She tried to teach me how to quilt.
现在回想那段时光，天哪，我真是无比珍惜。她教了我很多东西。我是说，我开始把它们列出来，不分先后。她教我开乘坐式割草机。她教我开车。她教我钩针编织。她。她教我钩针编织。她试图教我做拼布。
I was just not very patient. She was an amazing quilter. She would put us all to work, all of her grandkids in her garden. The woman could grow anything. And I would spend hours with her in her kitchen. She always had something from her garden that she was making or our chores
我只是不太有耐心。她是个出色的拼布大师。她会让我们所有人，她所有的孙子孙女都在她的菜园里干活。这个女人什么都能种。我会和她在厨房里待上几个小时。她总是用菜园里的东西做点什么，或者让我们做家务
that she would have us do. And it's so interesting because, you know, your parents might give you a chore and you're like, oh, but my grandmother would give me a chore and I delighted in it. I was like, what can I do? One time she taught me how to make homemade ice cream using the peaches that she had picked from her garden. And, you know, in sort of going back and remembering, I have this book that she made me and I started to go through it. I had saved all of her cards and letters. She was a very big believer in writing letters and cards.
她会让我们做。这太有趣了，你知道，你父母可能会让你做家务，你会觉得，哦，但我的祖母让我做家务，我却乐在其中。我会想，我能做什么？有一次她教我如何用她从菜园里摘的桃子制作自制冰激凌。而且，你知道，在某种程度上回顾和记忆时，我保留了她为我制作的这本书，我开始翻阅它。我保存了她所有的卡片和信件。她非常相信写信和卡片。
You got a card every year on your birthday to all of her grandkids. She had a ton and her great grandchildren, but she also wrote me a lot of letters. She put together this whole book for me. When I asked her one time, once, I said, I would love to know more about our family tree. She put together a whole book for me. Wow. Of birth certificates and marriage license and just on and on about our family history. Jenna, here's a picture of all her peaches. She would just send me pictures from her yard. And these are the things that just mean so much to me that I still find
你每年生日都会收到一张卡片，她所有的孙子孙女都会收到。她有很多，还有曾孙辈，但她也给我写了很多信。她为我整理了整本书。有一次我问她，我说，我很想更多地了解我们的家谱。她为我整理了整本书。哇。关于出生证明、结婚证，还有关于我们家族历史的种种。珍娜，这是她所有桃子的照片。她会把她院子里的照片发给我。这些事情对我意义重大，至今仍让我
ground me in my life now. She had a real heart for service. She volunteered in her community. She was a firm believer in, if you don't have something nice to say, then don't say anything at all. And I have these tangible mementos of her now. She made us all quilts by hand. She made each of her grandkids a little lacy cover for their baby Bible. But I look now in my own home and I see all these touchstones that are her. If you went in her house, she had so many pictures,
在生活中找到根基。她有一颗真正的服务之心。她在社区做志愿者。她坚信，如果你没有什么好话可说，那就什么也别说。现在我有了关于她的这些有形纪念品。她亲手给我们每个人做了拼布被。她给每个孙辈都做了一个小蕾丝婴儿圣经封套。但现在我环顾自己的家，我看到了所有这些属于她的触动。如果你去她家，她有那么多的照片，
like it almost looked cluttered because she just wanted everyone to see her family. And my house is so full of pictures. I once had a friend who was dating this new gal and she was very chic and she came over to my house and she walked in and she goes, oh, she goes, I feel like I'm in a grandma's house. And I think she meant it to be snarky,
看起来几乎像杂乱无章，因为她只想让每个人都看到她的家人。我的家里也摆满了照片。我曾经有个朋友带着新女友来，她非常时髦，她来到我家，一进门就说，哦，她说，我觉得我好像来到了奶奶家。我想她本意是想挖苦，
but I took it as such a compliment. I mean, my kitchen cabinets, I purposely picked the color that was my grandmother's wallpaper in her kitchen. Anyway, she was just full of grace and kindness. She was hardworking and earnest. I just loved and admired her. And as I went back through her letters and cards that she sent me over the years that I saved, I wanted to share just one sentence that she wrote to me.
但我把它当作一种恭维。我是说，我的厨房橱柜，我故意挑选了祖母厨房壁纸的颜色。总之，她充满优雅和善良。她勤劳而真诚。我非常爱她和钦佩她。当我翻看她这些年寄给我并被我保存下来的信件和卡片时，我想分享她写给我的一句话。
And it just kind of sums everything up. She had written me a card because I had just moved to Los Angeles. And I had shared with her that I was really struggling on how to start this dream of being an actor. No one in my family was an actor. This was a crazy thing for me to go to Los Angeles and do this. And the first sentence of her card she sent me said this, I believe you are on your way. There may be bumps in the road,
这简直概括了一切。她给我寄过一张卡片，因为我刚搬到洛杉矶。我曾向她倾诉，说我真的很纠结如何开始这个演员梦想。我的家族里没有人当演员。我去洛杉矶做这个真是个疯狂的决定。她寄给我的卡片的第一句话是这样说的：我相信你在路上了。路上可能会有坎坷，
but that makes the smooth part seem much better." So she's one of my biggest mentors. And I, you know, my happy place is my yard with my plants and my hummingbirds. She had the most amazing hummingbird feeder. It was just a regular one, but it hung outside her kitchen window and she would get a gazillion hummingbirds. And we would just sit there and visit at her kitchen table. And yeah, I'm so thankful that I had her in my life. Lady, I am so moved by your description of her because everything you're saying,
但这会让平坦的部分感觉更好。”所以她是我最大的导师之一。而且，你知道，我的快乐宝地是我的院子，里面有我的植物和蜂鸟。她有一个最棒的蜂鸟喂食器。那只是个普通的喂食器，但它挂在她厨房窗外，她能吸引无数的蜂鸟。我们就坐在她厨房的桌子旁聊天。是的，我很感激生命中有她。亲爱的，我对你对她的描述深深感动，因为你所说的一切，
it is just living through you. Like so clearly to me as your friend. Like when you said that when you walked in our house, she had tons of pictures. I mean, this is a thing about you. Like guys, Angela's fridge is covered. You put pictures in frames and I love how your home feels. But also like how many pictures of your hydrangea
它就像活在你身上一样。作为你的朋友，我看得很清楚。就像你说的那样，当你走进我们的家里，她有大量的照片。我是说，这就是你的特点。伙计们，安吉拉的冰箱贴满了。你把照片放进相框里，我喜欢你家的氛围。但还有，你可以给你的绣球花拍多少张照片？
can you take? I know. And that's the picture of the peaches right there. I know. You know, like she is living through you. Like this, I see her impact on you. So clearly as you described this, all the handwritten notes you've sent to me,
我知道。那就是桃子的照片。我知道。你知道吗，她就像活在你身上一样。就像这样，我看到了她对你的影响。正如你所描述的那样，你发给我的所有手写便签，
all of your digital clutter, it's all like, I'm like, I'm just seeing her. Yeah. Oh, thank you for sharing that. Yeah. I feel like even after all these years, I just got to know you even more deeply because you shared that.
你所有的数码杂物，这一切就像，我只想说，我看到了她。是的。哦，谢谢你分享这些。是的。我觉得即使历经这么多年，因为你的分享，我对你的了解更加深入了。
Oh, you would have just loved her. I have no doubt, I love you. Well, Jenna, I know you have a letter that really moved you that was sent in to us that you would like to share. I do. So this letter was from Omar R. in Williamsburg, Brooklyn. Here's what Omar said, First of all, day one listener here.
哦，你一定会喜欢她的。毫无疑问，我爱你。好吧，珍娜，我知道你有一封真正触动你的来信是别人寄给我们的，你想分享一下。是的。所以这封信来自布鲁克林威廉斯堡的奥马尔·R。奥马尔是这么说的：首先，我是第一天的老听众。
Your show and podcast has brought me so much joy and anytime I have anxiety, hearing you ladies talk really relaxes me and makes me feel like everything will be okay. My mentor story is unique in that I didn't know they were my mentors when I was younger. I was 21 years old at a bar in Brooklyn, and two older gentlemen sat next to me, and they overheard me talking to my friends and they said hi. They had just moved to the United States from France. We ended up talking most of the night and found out they had a dog who needed walking and taking care of every other month when they were back in France for business.
你们的节目和播客给我带来了巨大的欢乐，每当我感到焦虑时，听你们这些女士聊天真的能让我放松，让我觉得一切都会好起来的。我的导师故事很独特，因为我年轻时并不知道他们是我的导师。我21岁时在布鲁克林的一家酒吧里，两位年长的绅士坐在我旁边，他们无意中听到我和朋友们的聊天并向我打招呼。他们刚从法国搬到美国。我们最后聊了一整晚，发现他们有一只狗，每隔一个月当他们回法国出差时，需要有人遛狗和照顾。
They taught me everything I know about etiquette. They brought me to my first ever dinner parties, events, Broadway shows at 21. I didn't know about decorum, and honestly, I didn't know very much about respect. They believed in me and always encouraged me to work hard and make something with myself. Their kindness and motivation was what I needed as a lost 21-year-old. I walked their dog and sat their home for years. They moved back to France a few years ago, and I never fully got to thank them for everything
他们教会了我关于礼仪的一切。他们带我去参加我人生中的第一个晚宴、活动、百老汇演出。21岁时，我根本不懂礼仪，说实话，我对尊重也知之甚少。他们相信我，总是鼓励我努力工作，有所作为。作为一个迷茫的21岁年轻人，他们的善良和动力正是我所需要的。我帮他们遛狗并看家多年。几年前他们搬回了法国，我从未有机会完全感谢他们所教给我的一切
they taught me about life. So say yes to those who are older and wiser. Say yes to those who motivate you to pursue your dreams. Say yes to those who have positive intent for your life. I now help run a creative department for a tech company, a position I would have never had if they didn't always believe in me to pursue my dreams and never give up." And then Omar said, Thank you ladies for all that you do. Looking forward to hearing more and more stories y'all
关于生活的一切。所以，对那些年长且更有智慧的人说“好”。对那些激励你追求梦想的人说“好”。对那些对你的人生抱有善意的人说“好”。我现在帮助一家科技公司运营一个创意部门，如果不是他们始终相信我去追求梦想永不放弃，我绝不可能拥有这个职位。”然后奥马尔说：“谢谢女士们所做的一切。期待听到你们
have to share. Also, finally watched The Edge because of your podcast. Oh my gosh. And I now say to my friends, a good plan today is better than a perfect plan tomorrow. And I now say to my friends, a good plan today is better than a perfect plan tomorrow. And I have now become a mentor to my younger friends. And I owe it all to two random Frenchmen I met in a bar when I was 21. I'm 31 now. Aww. I just loved it.
分享更多更多的故事。另外，因为你们的播客，我终于看了《边缘》。哦，天哪。我现在对朋友们说，今天的完美计划不如明天的好计划。我现在对朋友们说，今天的完美计划不如明天的好计划。我现在已经成了年轻朋友们的导师。这一切都要归功于我21岁时在酒吧遇到的两个偶然的法国人。我现在31岁了。啊。我太喜欢了。
I did too, because it's the kindness and, you know, they were strangers. They were kind and they helped this young person, like have a sense of security, community, and that's a lifelong friendship. Yeah. That's wonderful. Yeah. Well, Jenna, I know you have a really special mentor you would like to share about.
我也很喜欢，因为这就是善良，而且，你知道，他们是陌生人。他们很善良，帮助这个年轻人建立了一种安全感、归属感，这是一段终生的友谊。是的。太棒了。是的。好吧，珍娜，我知道你有一位非常特别的导师想要分享。
I would. I wanna share about my breast cancer mentor, Clea Shearer. In all of my talking about my journey so far, I haven't had a chance to share about Clea, maybe because it's so emotional. But after I got my diagnosis, the only person I'd ever known who had had breast cancer was Christina Applegate. We had done a movie together, Hall Pass. It was after she had been through her surgery. And we shared a lot about it on that movie. She's such a wonderful person. After I got my diagnosis, I texted Christina and I said, hey, do you have a minute to talk?
是的。我想分享我的乳腺癌导师克利娅·谢尔（Clea Shearer）。在我迄今为止讲述自己的经历时，我一直没有机会分享关于克利娅的事，也许是因为这太情绪化了。但在我确诊后，我唯一知道得过乳腺癌的人是克里斯蒂娜·艾伯盖特。我们一起拍过一部电影《通行证》。那是在她做完手术之后。我们在那部电影里分享了很多这方面的经历。她是一个非常好的人。我确诊后，给克里斯蒂娜发信息说，嘿，你有空聊聊吗？
And are you somewhere private? I have something personal to share with you. She texted back, I'm alone, call me. And I called her and I said, I have breast cancer. And Christina, who is amazing, she goes, I fucking knew it. I knew it was breast cancer or MS. I knew that's why you wanted to talk to me in private. She was like, damn it, damn it.
你在私密的地方吗？我有私事想跟你分享。她回信说，我一个人，打电话给我。我打给她说，我得了乳腺癌。克里斯蒂娜人太棒了，她说，我他妈早就知道了。我知道是乳腺癌或多发性硬化症。我知道这就是为什么你想私下跟我谈。她当时说，该死，该死。
Oh God. It was just so perfect because I was like, I know, right? She's like, God, I mean, God, I just love her. So she was talking to me and it was very clear at this point that I was going to have a lot of treatments, that chemotherapy was gonna be part of my treatment. And she said, Jenna, my breast cancer journey was so long ago, and it did not include all the things
噢天哪。这简直太完美了，因为当时我想，对吧？她说，天哪，我是说，天哪，我太喜欢她了。所以她一直在跟我聊天，当时很明显我将要接受很多治疗，化疗将是我治疗的一部分。她说，珍娜，我的乳腺癌经历是很久以前的事了，其中并不包含所有这些
that you're gonna have to go through. But I have a friend who just went through so many of these similar things. Her name is Clea. Can I put you in touch? I know she's a stranger to you, but trust me. So I texted Clea. Just someone you'd never met.
你将要经历的事情。但我有一个朋友刚刚经历了许多类似的事情。她叫克利娅。我能介绍你们认识吗？我知道她对你是个陌生人，但相信我。所以我给克利娅发了信息。只是一个你从未见过的人。
Never met. Right. She sprang into action in a way that I don't even know how to ever thank her for. She answered every question. She comforted all of my nerves. She offered suggestions and guidance, but most of all, she was just a person
从未见过。是的。她立即采取行动，让我不知该如何感谢她。她回答了每一个问题。她抚平了我所有的紧张情绪。她提供了建议和指导，但最重要的是，她只是一个
who had done it before and was OK. And I needed to hear from that person so much. And she has become an absolute dear friend of mine through all of this. We are still friends. She still counsels me, and she has inspired me to take on that role for others. And so-
经历过这一切并且安然无恙的人。我非常需要听到这样的人说话。通过这一切，她成为了我非常亲密的好朋友。我们现在还是朋友。她仍然在开导我，她激励我也为其他人扮演这样的角色。所以——
And you are. And I have been. Yeah. And what it taught me was that going through this whole thing, this whole mess of breast cancer and treatments, if I could somehow make it useful, if I could somehow help another person feel less scared, less alone, if there was any part of my sharing that was a comfort to another woman.
你也是。我一直是。是的。它教会我的是，经历这一切，乳腺癌和治疗的整个混乱过程，如果我能以某种方式让它变得有价值，如果我能以某种方式帮助另一个人减少恐惧、减少孤独，如果我的分享哪怕有一点点能给另一个女人带来慰藉。
Anything you had learned, anything that- Anything. From this experience where you could help someone. Yes. Yeah. I wanted to do that. So while I haven't shared maybe a whole lot publicly, I have shared privately with other breast cancer patients. And it's a thing that Clea taught me how to do.
你学到的任何东西，任何——任何东西。从这段可以帮助别人的经历中。是的。是的。我想那样做。所以虽然我可能没有公开分享太多，但我与其他的乳腺癌患者进行过私下分享。这是克利娅教我做的事情。
She absolutely taught me how to be that for other people because she was that for me. And that just kind of like open book sharing just meant the world to me. And so thank you, Clea. You guys might know Clea from the home edit or she's one of the hosts of ABC's home makeover home edition.
她绝对教会了我如何为其他人做到这一点，因为她曾为我做到过。这种毫无保留的分享对我的意义太重大了。所以谢谢你，克利娅。你们可能从《收纳人生》（The Home Edit）或者ABC的家居改造节目《Home Makeover Home Edition》中认识克利娅。
Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah, she's amazing. You've always talked to me about Clea, but I never knew anything about her other than that she was the person that you could confide in during this time and get knowledge from. Yes. I mean, since we're talking about her, you can actually watch it on Hulu. It's so great. If you want to know this woman and how great she
哦，我不知道这个。是的，她太棒了。你总是跟我提起克利娅，但我对她的了解仅限于在这段艰难时期你可以向她吐露心声并从中获取知识的人。是的。我是说，既然我们在谈论她，你其实可以在Hulu上观看。太棒了。如果你想了解这个女人以及她有多么
is, there's a whole type of mentorship that happens as she's going through and helping people as she's going through and helping people like build a new home and like rebuild their life through their homes. And like who she is is so clear. I have heard her name for a year. And this is the first time. I mean, I just knew how special she was to you. I'm so glad you shared about her
伟大，她有一种独特的指导方式，当她经历这一切并帮助别人重建新家、通过家来重建生活时。她的为人如此清晰。我听过这个名字一年了。这是第一次。我是说，我只知道她对你有多特别。我很高兴你分享了关于她的事情
because I have never met her. I just hear so much about your friendship and what she's helped you journey through. And I just want to give her a big hug. So I need to meet her. Well, you have to meet her someday. And you know, she works with her best friend, Joanna. Okay. And I got to go out to lunch with the two of them. And Lady, I was like, is this what it's like to go to lunch with me and you? Oh, really? Because these two are such BFFs. They're so cute. So we have to have a total BFF lunch sometime.
因为我从未见过她。我只是经常听到你们的友谊以及她如何帮助你度过这段旅程。我只想给她一个大大的拥抱。所以我需要见她一面。好吧，你总有一天会见到她的。你知道的，她和她的好闺蜜乔安娜一起工作。好的。我有幸和她俩一起吃了午餐。亲爱的，我当时想，跟我还有你一起吃午餐是这种感觉吗？哦，真的吗？因为这两个人真是超级闺蜜。她们太可爱了。所以我们以后一定要安排一次超级闺蜜午餐。
Let's do that. I'd love that. But I feel like I'll get emotional when I meet her just because I just know that there were so many things that you needed during that time that myself and like your friend group and even some of your family members, we didn't speak the language, you know, we didn't have the understanding
那就这么办吧。我很乐意。但我觉得当我见到她时我会情绪激动，因为我知道在那段时期里你有很多需要，而我和你的朋友圈甚至你的一些家庭成员，我们不懂那种语言，你知道，我们没有那种理解
and we gave you everything we could, but you needed a community that understood what you were going through and Clea was a big part of that for you. She was. I mean, you would say to me, if I was nervous about something, you'd say, well, what would, what does Clea say? What did Clea think? Like, have you talked to Clea about that? Yes. So you definitely know her. I know her through, yeah. Yeah. I'm so glad you shared. I know how important she is to you. I'm so happy that you shared.
我们给了你我们所能给予的一切，但你需要一个理解你正在经历什么的社区，而克利娅是其中的重要部分。她是。我是说，你会对我说，如果我为什么事感到紧张，你会说，嗯，克利娅会怎么说？克利娅是怎么想的？就像，你跟克利娅谈过这个吗？是的。所以你绝对了解她。我通过……是的。是的。我很高兴你分享了。我知道她对你有多重要。我很高兴你分享了。
Yeah. Thank you everyone for listening to this podcast that has gone in so many different directions today. So many different directions. I did not expect. This is a joy. We love doing it. So thank you so much for listening. Thank you for your letters that you write in. Just all of it.
是的。谢谢大家收听这期走向了许多不同方向的播客。去了好多不同的方向。我完全没有预料到。这真是一种快乐。我们很喜欢做这个。所以非常感谢你们的收听。谢谢你们写来的信。一切的一切。
Yeah, and thank you Kelly Cantley, Nate Fetterman, Ellie Kemper for helping us out with this episode as well. Yeah. Well, we'll see you next week. See you next week. All right, go hug your mentor. ["Odyssey Theme Song"] Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
是的，还要感谢凯利·坎特利、内特·费特曼、埃莉·肯珀对这期节目的帮助。是的。好吧，我们下周见。下周见。好了，去抱抱你的导师吧。["奥德赛主题曲"] 感谢收听“办公室女士”。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Braden. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“办公室女士”是奥德赛呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。奥德赛的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士”由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡树》。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。